fossils have driven at our understanding
of ancient species for centuries but DNA
is changing the game we are walking
around on DNA from the present and if we
Dig Down DNA from the past now a team of
scientists have sequenced
the recovered twice the age of what we
previously thought was possible the DNA
is 2 million years old and from it
they've reconstructed a detailed and
surprising picture of an ancient world
we could basically see this whole
ecosystem come to life and that was
amazing it was just amazing
SK villuslev is a geneticist and
paleontologist who helped Pioneer a
technique which uses ancient DNA to
explore the past if you look around here
right we are the Zoological Museum in
Cambridge we see bones all over the
place and this is this has been the
traditional way people were looking at
the past but I mean fossils are
generally very rare fossilization
requires a very specific conditions to
preserve things like bone and even then
paleontologists often have to be lucky
to find fossils DNA on the other hand is
everywhere every single cell right in
the body contains DNA and a ground sloth
like this or an elephant they are
shedding DNA all the time to the
surroundings right so it's just if I do
like this
DNA will be on this table for me this is
called environmental DNA or e-dna it's
been a core part of sk's research for
decades and is now a thriving field in
paleontology but it wasn't always I
remember it was during my doctors and I
went into
you know my supervisor and I said to him
well I think maybe I will try to test
whether DNA from animals and plants can
survive in the soil right because I I
was sitting out looking at the window
and I saw leaves fall down from the
trees and the dark taking a crap on the
street the question is what happens to
the DNA and I said well maybe it's
surviving in the sediments and he
laughed at me and said I've never heard
anything as stupid in my life now sk's
research involves looking for DNA
preserved in ancient soils the DNA
molecules are electrically charged and
some of the sediment particles you know
in the soil are electric the charge so
DNA will bind to these sediment
particles and that will reduce the
chemical degradation rate of the DNA the
colder it is the better the DNA
preservation so one of the best places
to look for any ancient DNA is ground
that's been continuously Frozen
so-called permafrost
so in 2006 SK and colleagues headed to
Greenland in search of Frozen ancient
dirt it's what we call an Arctic desert
I mean it's it's a Stony area where you
can just see life is really struggling
to survive and so are you when you are
there to be honest the team took samples
from a location known as the cap
Copenhagen formation these were cause of
permafrost the oldest parts of which
dated back two million years but when
they tried looking for DNA in 2006 they
were out of luck we tried with those
techniques that were available at the
time and we got nothing right I mean and
the general notion at that time was well
DNA can maximum survive for one million
years so it wasn't that surprising but
every time we made improvements in our
DNA extraction methods or our sequencing
abilities we went back to the cap
Copenhagen samples and tried right and
we failed and we failed and we failed
until a couple of years ago
and suddenly we got a hit as the
technology developed the team were able
to extract more and more short fragment
bound to the sediment and then to
amplify these using modern day
biomolecular techniques at that stage it
was like whoa we got DNA out that is two
million years old right the second war
was I think when when we got the animal
dnao they were finally able to piece
together the DNA fragments and build a
picture of what this ancient environment
might have looked like we had a
breakthrough and we could we could
basically see or this this whole
ecosystem come to life and that was
amazing it was just amazing there was
Masters runs running around reindeers
geese hairs also marine animals like the
horseshoe crab which suggested a much
warmer environment even in the sea
during that time which was also
surprising the picture looked very
different from that of modern Greenland
mastodons an ancient relative of
elephants were a particularly unexpected
find no one
had predicted that Mastodon should be
around it's found in North America
and Greenland at that time was also an
island so it was separated from North
America just as today and therefore
people didn't think that animals like
mastodons could get there right but it
well it did right so either it must have
been swimming from the Canadian Islands
into Greenland or potentially walked
over the sea ice Mastodon fossils have
been found in various sites in North
America but never in Greenland and
according to SK this demonstrates the
benefits of using e-dna to study ancient
ecosystems plantology obviously you can
do more than just identify the bone
right so if you find parts of a skeleton
you can also say things about Locomotion
for example you can say something about
whether it was heard or damaged you know
during life for example DNA can't tell
you anything about that but what DNA can
is it gives you information about the
genetic code itself it gives us the
opportunity to follow evolution in
action basically right you can actually
see how species are genetically evolving
and changing it also gives an
opportunity to not only see it on a
species level but a whole ecosystem
level the use of e-dna is growing among
paleontologists as techniques improve
and SK is already thinking about how to
extract even older DNA I think it's
definitely possible to go back further I
I really think so and I think so for
for at least one important reason we can
see that some of the DNA that is
captured in the sediments we are not
really able at this stage to properly
release when we become capable of doing
that and we're working on it obviously
then I think you will Target a whole new
pool of DNA and I think that will bring
us significantly further back the
previous record for ancient DNA was 1.2
million years and it belonged to a
mammoth Frozen in Siberian permafrost so
sk's 2 million year old DNA is already a
huge jump but there may be a limit to
the oldest DNA that can be recovered
theoretically the oldest permafrost that
could still exist is 2.6 million years
old before that it was too warm for
permafrost to form but it's not just
about finding the oldest DNA getting
these kind of techniques to work in
different kinds of environments is
another big challenge obviously in
Greenland we got the sample because it's
cold and this is good for long-term DNA
preservation so it is really a good
place to start if you want to get
millions DNA there are millions of years
whether it will also work out in you can
say other settings like temperate
settings for example I wouldn't exclude
that possibility at all because
temperature although it is important is
not the only determining factor of
course the study of DNA alone has its
limitations without the fossil record we
wouldn't know much about what these
animals actually looked like but when it
comes to the more recent past Edna is an
exciting new part of the paleontologists
toolkit environmental DNA is becoming
more and more actual that people are
using in order to describe communities
right so I think it will always be you
can say a combination of tools and I'm
sure also we will in the future see
tools that I can't even imagine now to
be honest even now there are many more
ecosystems yet to be explored
explore environmental DNA and perhaps
many more surprises yet to be uncovered
it's great I mean this is why you do
science right it's for those movements
you know where you're just like oh my
God I mean it's it's just changing the
way we looked at things and this is the
dream of a scientist right